your doctor may perform a
percutaneous endoscopic gastrostomy or pg
to insert a feeding tube into
your stomach
if you are unable to feed by
mouth for a long time
digestion of food begins in your
mouth when you eat food it is
pushed into your esophagus a tube
muscle that carries food to the
stomach where it is digested  or
absorb food due to
esophageal cancer oral surgery or
stroke major surgery trauma
burns or anorexia inflammation of the
pancreas or radiation therapy or
inflammatory bowel disease affecting the
small intestine
before the procedure you will receive an
intravenous sedative to help you
relax you will be given anesthesia
the
most commonly used p&g placement procedure
is the push method during
this procedure
the doctor will insert a
flashlight endoscope through the mouth and
slide it down the esophagus and into the
inside the stomach a camera attached
to the endoscope will produce pictures of the
inside of the stomach which will be
viewed on a video monitor
and then the doctor will insert a needle
through the skin into the stomach where
the pg tube will be placed while doing so
the doctor will use  the endoscope to
place the end of the needle into the
stomach and enclose it with a
wire mesh then pass a thin wire
through that needle into
the stomach attach the endoscope to the
wire and it will pull the endoscope and wire
out of  the mouth at that moment a
thin wire will enter through the
front part of the abdomen towards the
interior of the stomach and continue  will go
up into the mouth
the doctor will attach the
pg feeding tube to the wire outside the
mouth by
gently pulling on the other end of the
wire
the doctor will withdraw the tube through
the mouth into the esophagus and stomach
continuing to pull until the tip
of the tube comes out  through the
stomach and abdomen incisions
a soft, round stopper attached to the
part of the tube that remains inside the
stomach
will secure it in place the
outside of the tube will also be secured
with a stopper and a sterile gauze pad will be
placed around the injection site
alternative push method incision the doctor will start in the
same way using an endoscope to
guide the lead through the
abdominal wall into the stomach
however instead of pulling the pg tube
through the mouth the doctor will
push it directly  into
the stomach over the wire after the
procedure
you will continue to receive
fluids intravenously for a  o o two
days once the
digestive tract is confirmed to be working you
will receive clear liquids through the
pg tube if you tolerate clear liquids you
will receive a feeding formula
through the pg tube